hi my name is Devin Reeve and I'm the
one of the producers and the line
producer of a rock and a hard place
how'd you become involved in the project
um why was friends with James and James
hit me up saying that he was directing
this amazing pilot and we did a
conference call with David and next
thing I know we were prepping the next
day so that's how fast to happen do you
think usually happen that fast something
well normally you you'll get hired but
then there's like a week maybe that
there's a downtime before we actually
start your work and prepping for film
but because of the holidays coming up
that we decided to rush it so as soon as
we were hired the next day we were up
and running trying to get everything
ready before the Thanksgiving holiday so
we probably prepped this and about eight
days and so the prep involves what can
you take us from your first step sure it
was a prep involves well casting locked
in the script
finding your locations me define
producer doing a budget allocating money
to where it needs to go hiring the crew
getting all the vendors set up for the
for the equipment getting the gear doing
a tech Scout where we all go around to
the different locations and all the
departments have a chance to see
everything before they when we actually
start shooting so they can prep for that
location so a table read and then just a
lot of a lot of detail stuff that has to
happen so we were trying to the original
plan was to shoot this to Monday after
the Thanksgiving holiday where you have
everything those clothes for four days
nothing is open and I was like guys we
have to we kind of move this too we have
push it by two days there's no way we
can we will hurt the production if we
just go right into it and have those
extra two days to to get everything
ready and thankful thankfully we did
there's a lot of your prep behind the
computer and then once you get here it's
more hands-on it is yeah most most of my
prep is phone calls emails computers is
basically just call them I call them the
resources that I use over and over again
going hey it's Devon I got another
project this is what I need and which is
once you've done it long enough you have
those relationships a call which is
fantastic
but then again sometimes is you know you
got to make sure everything comes within
that budget that's been allocated for a
project and depending on there's any
special effects or stunts or animals or
kids you have to take all that into
account which can be a little tricky
sometimes but we always we always pull
it off do you have some sort of template
on your computer that's that it's like a
checklist for you that you work within I
do we have a it's called a
pre-production checklist so we'll know
then we have a giant board and so we'll
start writing down what we've done and
checking it off and we'll take the cast
will put the cast up on the walls so we
can see who the so we can start
visualizing the cast and seeing how they
match up within the system within the
story how long have you been doing this
I grew up an actor and probably about 12
years ago I transitioned into producing
as well so now I still act but also
produce and that line produced as well
which kind of covers a broad spectrum
and that direct every once in a while so
it's a music video as a why now but
acting and producing is really the
passion that drives me to stay in this
what type of temperament and skills does
producer or line producer need to have
patience a lot of patience yeah
it's that in there it's really people
management skills and oddly enough it's
just being able to multitask and manage
a large group of people who are all
different personalities you know your
wardrobe and your makeup are usually the
more kind of fashionable type people
where in your Genie guys are a little
more you know a little more rough you
know they're like the blue-collar
workers you can go yeah no offense I'll
just give it to me straight
yeah these guys are you know there's
hang up lice or they're carrying heavy
equipment and they're driving the trucks
and it's you know so it just takes the
people who are just really driven to
come out here and work 12 13 hours a day
and get
done so no matter that the department
it's about the the ability of people who
really come here and have a great
personality and positive attitude
they've worked 12 14 hour days and get
the job done so for me when I actually
hire anyone from the PA to the grip to
the capper to whenever the department I
usually base it off their personality
and the type of energy that they bring
in the interview because to meet anyone
can learn a skill set anyone can really
you know build that resume evacuates and
but they have a bad attitude or negative
energy or and their morale is not very
high like I won't hire them oh here they
are
because I want my success to be ran at
the highest level so when the problems
always happen on set so if something
happens almost some people a team that's
gonna say that we got this we know how
to get around this and and and keep it
and keep the ball rolling it sounds like
in some sense you have to be a chameleon
to deal with different personalities and
maybe they're not bad personalities but
they just receive information in
different ways yeah absolutely and I
think I was smart in the way I went
about transit you know learning about
producing is when I was younger I worked
for a production company but when I
moved to I just focused on acting and
before I've shot my first film I've
spent a year working production that
called up all my friends I've worked it
and said hey can I come work in your
department so I for myself I worked like
in catering I mean I got crafty I did
work in my gross grip which I would
never do again but much respect to those
guys I take Kevin email work to every
department because I wanted to
understand the fundamentals of how about
department worked and I thought I
thought it's a producer that would be be
great for me to be able to communicate
properly with those guys to no one to
understand their terminology to know
what they need it to know what they
didn't need it when their life we want
this but you really don't need it you
want it and we can't afford it or yeah
we can't afford it sounds like a lot of
- what you do is to assure people that
things are going to be fine and then you
fix it behind the scenes yes thank you
yeah we never went to the production
team or the crew to really know what
we're dealing with behind the scenes you
know so for example we had something
happened the other day which was we
couldn't keep under wraps because an
actor just didn't show up
sure sure so it sounds like that happens
is you can't keep it on the Rosebud
right we always have a solution and we
always have a anybody this is what you
deal with when you're worried that
you're in charge this right man
appreciate it
easy call c-47s for whatever reasons to
me they're clothespins clothespins yeah
I remember drawing my laundry um I
forgot why they a lot of the terminology
is interesting because it comes from
like that when they were making movies
in the 20s and 30s they just came up
with random names for things like this
yeah but yeah so it is we want to keep
everything kind of you know find the
seams and always have a plan a B and C
and there's something goes wrong we
resolve and that's really the biggest
job as a producer is problem solving on
the fly you know and making sure that
things keep moving in terms of the
budget what are you spending the most
money on and and where are you able to
kind of cut back a little bit oh it's a
pendulum use production um a lot a lot
of productions it's special effects some
of the productions or you're spending a
lot of money on talent you know the crew
alley is Alec allocates probably between
1/4 and a half of your budget you know
depending how long you're shooting but
it's kind of a fine balance between all
the departments really but usually if
it's a special-effects film that will
take up the majority of a large chunk of
the money how do you deal with neighbors
that maybe don't want you to shoot in
the neighborhood or they're super
curious and they want to be part of the
production because oh no this is LA but
still everybody's still when they see
the the trucks and and possible talent
and the camera people go through a wide
variety of attitudes emotions yeah
la is interesting because they either
one complaint and if we're permanent you
know loners were permitted properly
there's nothing they can really do but
get air
now they can't come out and say we can't
you can't shoot my put my house on the
scene or you can't do this unless you
pay me and you know sometimes we'll just
say here's the next amount of money just
to leave us alone but most for the most
part Nellie people are usually usually
pretty chill
unless you're shooting overnight like
goober this neighborhood if we were
shooting overnight we would then have to
be very quiet hours we have to be very
quiet and cost you know respectful of
the neighbors but it's still challenging
when you're shooting overnights
in a neighborhood because you know
people have day jobs do you have to you
have to get up early we shot something
last year and we had a night shoot it
was a horror film and of course the girl
comes running out of the house screaming
in the side 3:00 in the morning and the
cops show up because the neighbor
thought someone was getting like mugged
so that's interesting but people really
really don't bother you that much I just
did two movies in Utah we'd shot a film
and we did a Bollywood film last year in
Vegas which was interesting and we shot
on the strip and we gathered a large
crowd gathered around us because we were
coming right in from the Bellagio and
some other places and it was interesting
because the stars of the movie and even
the director are huge mega stars in
India and so there was a lot of Indian
tourists there for the holiday so they I
mean we find out like 5060 people
watching this and they were like signing
autographs and that was that was that
was pretty cool because shooting in LA
no one really cares sure except for
parking I was just wondering in terms of
like parking in the neighborhood I know
because parking in LA is an issue yeah
so how do you try to appease the
neighborhoods usually or if your
neighbors upset normally we have parking
lots there okay yeah we will find places
like this location we'll find a locater
nice Church and instead of paying a
parking lot for the money that we don't
have don't end up donating money to the
church to use their parking lot oh this
is nice so they're very good very polite
and long as nothing's going on at the
church there they're really really nice
about it I'm actually shot in a church
parking lot two days ago they never
everyone came over and saw this and I
got with us for a little bit and
so we were the you know it's kind of a
nice gesture to get back to the church
and so versus just renting and you know
paying ridiculous money for a parking
lot that's going to overcharge you Devon
when you first received a script as a
producer what are some of the things
that you're looking at and you need to
give a writer-director feedback on and
then also when you receive a script as a
line producer the same thing okay
when I first receive a script I I read
it and way I usually based a job off it
just it's a script is good or if as a
potential to be good so what we'll do is
if I'm brought on board we will have
what will I'll worry it will do notes on
it will work with the other producers
and the director to get the to get it
where it needs to be to make sure things
are really flowing smoothly the
continuity is there that's nothing that
doesn't make any sense and that it's
just a good story because at the
producer we want to tell good stories
you know we don't want to tell bad
stories so that's the first and foremost
thing that we look at the character and
the content that's in the story as the
line producer I look at it and go well
what budget do you what what's the
target budget you want to shoot this at
and I will read it and the first thing
I'll say after that is a man you know
that you don't yeah just my close up man
it's part of a producer job dad I'm just
messing with you so I don't like hit
line producer I find out what the what
the target budget is and then I'll read
the script and we'll say great we can
actually do this for the budget you want
to do it at or go you can't make this
for this budget or you can do this for
the budget but you're risking the
quality of the production and the
quality the crew is going to be and you
can be there's they're gonna be mad and
bake it off there because it's not going
to be the film that you want well I had
that happen on another film and know we
can make it for this and I'm like you
can't you can't
a guy who liked being lit on fire you
got stumps and every other scenes are
the car chase I'm let you can't know you
need like another couple hundred ran but
I cover myself and go won't make it work
and I put it in the email I'm just
stating for the record I said that you
can't do this for that just for the
record so if we go over it's not on me
and of course we went over and I told
their producer the the executive Peter
so said this is the original budget I
submitted and this is the budget that we
came in at and they were like two
thousand dollars off
so when they were fine with it but it's
just I think a lot of people write it
you know especially writers they're
people who are writers or directors or
writers and producers and actors they
get some merit in their script that they
don't I mean it's important to take the
advice of someone else and not be so
married to it because people are going
to see things that you don't see and you
know when you hire someone you hire them
for a reason you have to trust them and
listen to them and so that's the
important fact I think even as a as a
writer or director and you bring a
project is like you have to listen to
your team because they're going to do
its best they're they have your back you
know you can't you can't if you don't
trust if you don't trust that then you
shouldn't be working with them so that's
the biggest thing is just making sure
that it's you know that you've given
everybody what they want even the
investors what they want you giving the
writer what they want you're the
director what they want there's pink
shirt just you know it gets done and
that looks amazing cuz you don't want
begging you one last thing you want is
an investment put money into it and then
when it's done you go wow this is a
piece of like nobody wants to do
that so like why not do it right what is
the biggest misconception or the biggest
thing that people think an investor or
writer director thinks that they can
scale back the budget on but in reality
they can't and you have to kind of let
them know anyone who wants to does
always say okay if you're going to do in
this day and age because the technology
a lot of people have to do things on a
low budget scale I know whether it's the
ultra low budget or a low budget you
know do two different categories and
it's like if you have if you have kids
if you have animals if you have stunts
those are things you can not scale back
on
you gotta have a studio teacher there if
you have kids kids coming to work or
something have an hour so it's gonna
shorten your day if you have animals you
get a high or an animal trainer unless
it's a dog that's already trained if you
have stunts
you know stunt guys would come out but
it's a minimum for sack stumps and you
know stunt guys aren't gonna you know
work for below certain things especially
they're gonna be set on fire or whatnot
so I mean there's always a way around
certain things and people would do it
but again you're jeopardizing the
quality of people you're bringing on
board so I always I think a lot of
people they make a scrip and go we want
to make it for this versus I say write a
scrip that matches your budget don't
write a scrip and go with us we can make
it work for this much money anyway know
if you find a script that is a five
million dollar script and you're in
you only have five hundred thousand it's
not gonna work so you need to scale that
script down and make it work for the
budget that you have something that's no
problem mistake a lot of people make is
they don't make the but the script match
the budget they actually have and then
conversely what do you think people
spend too much money on but really they
could scale back on is it location
thinking they need some amazing place
but really you're just gonna see a
little bit of it yeah I mean in LA is
different because this everyone is very
familiar without family works on here so
you can get lucky and get some great
deals on locations but a lot lots of
times it's you know people are charging
you a lot of money you know in Utah we
got locations for free here for like a
thousand bucks Wow
you know which is really hard to do here
we've done it but it knows personal
favors but I mean I don't know it's
I think a lot of people when I spoke
about the same amount of money I mean
there's you're a hard cost of like money
you're going to spend regardless know
your crew the bigger mistake is people
overpay people when they don't have the
budget for it that's the biggest thing
it's really just being mismanaged
because you can you know if I'm if we
jump on a you know a two million dollar
movie you know the crew is gonna be paid
three four hours a day you plus their
overtime you know if you're doing a five
hundred thousand dollar movie people
working for 150 200 today you know so
but yeah I think a lot of people just
mismanage that and they go oh well it's
this much you know $500,000 and we're
going to still pay them for her at all
today the thing it's just they overpay
people I think that's the biggest thing
they're not they're not aware or they
try to take care of their friends or
they you know they don't they do so
manager right so let's suppose they do
find a cheaper location in Utah or some
other state then what are they weighing
in terms of the cost to bring people in
or should we tire hire excuse me local
talent like what what are some of them
the the questions that you ask if you
have an la-based production but I decide
to take it to another state that's
cheaper what are you looking at to make
sure that it all balances out and that
you're not spending the same working
we're comparing the the cost to crew
putting them up in a hotel their travel
paying their per diem rate for the show
and we're weighing that against how much
we were spent on locations okay and so
you kind of tally it all up and
whichever comes out less is the better
option yeah yeah so for the two hallmark
movies we did the do it worked out the
better to do it in Utah it still was
about the same but the setting was right
and we've brought two actors in from LA
and then everyone else actor wise for
local hire actors you know so that kind
of helped with the budget as well and
then I didn't mind produce that one but
I was a part of the team the production
team but doing it out of state project
it's just really about the the per diems
and all that versus you know
just keeping it here you know if you're
going to spend 25,000 in locations or
attend out $30,000 in locations here and
you can do that for $10,000 in Utah then
it it makes sense to take care of
everybody up there it balances out
because you know the money is still
going to be sent you know the money's
money so I have five five five million
dollars as a million dollars it just
depends on where I put it
sure and are you also looking at tax
credits and and targeting those states
first to see if that works then if it
doesn't yes yeah we yeah basically yeah
so a lot of times it will be it depends
on the what the story setting is so if
it's you know it's if it's evergreens
and rolling hills or mountains it's not
gonna be our way you know you have to go
somewhere else to get that setting page
there's a lot of exterior shoots so then
if you are going to apply for the tax
credit who do you contact within that
state I just have no Commission okay and
then as they're like awaiting certain
states take longer for certain you know
yeah you stay with the tax incentive is
a little different where it's like South
Carolina you can go there and those you
know give you check when you arrive
notice days in other states it takes 30
days just it just depends on the state
how they ever structured Devon let's
take the hypothetical budget of a
million dollars let's say you have a
writer director that says that's what
they have what is your litmus test to
make sure that that's exactly what will
fall under that amount what are you
doing what are you testing to make sure
the focus
Wow once I read the script in that
there's a million dollar budget I'll
read the script and first I'll look at
how many locations there are how many
actors there are and there's any stunts
those are the first three things I look
at and then based off that I will go
through and again it also how many pages
of the script because if it's you know
if it's a 90 page script then we're
gonna shoot for three weeks are we gonna
shoot for four weeks if it's 120 pages
are we going to shoot for five weeks or
six weeks so that extends the budget you
know so based on the number of pages
that's that has a lot to do with it also
so after I do all that then what's like
first I'll go okay we can shoot this in
say four weeks and then I go this is the
crew that I'm gonna they're not plugging
all the crew that were I know it's
necessary that we're gonna need to have
for the type of film that it is once I
get the crew all done then I go back and
do the cast and go that way because once
I have the hard numbers and probably
crew
that's just we're gonna need those guys
it's no negotiation we need those guys
benefit of how much for catering and how
much for crafty you know that and then
we're left with do the locations and
they I do they do the actors which I
have all the hard cost in I go back and
go you got this much to pay actors you
got this much for locations what do you
want to do you know you won't put more
money towards actors and less towards
locations but again you have to allocate
enough money to two locations and make
sure you can get them and they you know
then he got a there's always like a 10%
contingency in in the budget that we
allocate and then you got the factory
and post-production let's the folks
production is being done all in-house
and you're not going to include that in
the budget production budget but the
same thing because the budgets that we I
normally do I'm sure it's the same for
lot of line producers they're just
constant there ever-changing so I'll
have a budget and allocate certain
amount of money and I always kind of
overcompensate in the beginning because
then we I know once I start negotiating
rates and whatnot and start fitting in
row numbers the budget always seems to
the numbers of things said the money is
the same it's just the money is just
moving around so I find up saving $5,000
on locations that $5,000 just gonna go
towards something else that needs more
that's gonna need more money so it's
kind of looks like a little little
puzzle is constantly shifting as we go
through the production what about
production insurance and like what
what's the normal deductible and I mean
I know nothing about production so it
just depends on how much you want to pay
so if I pay $7,000 for insurance it's
probably about twenty five hundred
dollar deductible okay I can pay more
and have $1,000 to bucks
this depends on the project because
these project based on what's involved
in it that the insurance are different
and what's the term for the so the the
term would be for the term of the
production right so so if it's a four
week thing and you go over how do you
then renew the interest right don't know
I'm gonna do like a like physical
four-week shoot doesn't normally do like
a to like a two-month policy oh that's
pretty much policy which it covers
through prep and all the way through
post-production okay and then if you
needed to do any reshoots would unless
it was in that time period you'd have to
then renew it yes yeah during anything
any time during production we can always
extend it
why can't even they feed into the rehab
cost I think I was not much more money
just to say we want to do it for six
months versus three months and there's
some companies that just constantly
carry production insurance they just
always have it which makes it nice and
easy but we usually tend to do because
each production is its own LLC we
usually cover that LLC separately so
then are you involved in getting the
paperwork to the Secretary of State or
whoever to do the articles of
incorporation and all that would you
have an attorney do that uh some
sometimes have an attorney do it
sometimes we as a place in Burbank at
school I forgot the name of it but
they'll know your self legal type they
give them everything and then like in 24
hours like they they're here or 48 hours
right here you go okay which is nice so
I really not have to deal with all that
sure what's going on Siri do we normally
have someone just do it for us okay and
so then once the LLC is established then
that entity lives on and and that covers
the film yeah once we establish the LLC
it just pretty it is
it's just forever going and so it's got
to pay the taxes on it and do all that
fun stuff out there paperwork paperwork
at the end of the year and reconcile
everything and but that's why we have
production accountants they did it they
do all that for us they enjoy all that
yeah here you go let me know how it is
yeah
which is uh we're running a little lower
budget production in
Larry Knight my business partner try to
uh we're looking at we could do all that
we did it but never again it's just it's
just too much work so this and one thing
about us because we know how we know how
to do everything it's just we have to
prevent ourself from going yeah yeah
yeah we can do that because we'll take
on too much and you know because we can
and it just is that's how we get
exhausted and because we don't take Alan
too much and it's it's better to have a
fresh someone dedicated to that one job
that can just stay without one job and
stays fresh and we all don't all get
burnt out sure and speaking of burnout
what do you do to renew yourself and how
much time do you give yourself between
projects um it depends I've come back me
and uh in Utah we shot those two films
back-to-back and so we had like a week
break however because we were in
production the week was not really a
break for us because we were still in
the office working it so we had two days
off in between but but typically after a
show is done I'll take a week and let's
go got a week to go do whatever and
sometimes I stay home and just relax and
get caught up and sometimes I go to met
your mountain and sometimes I see my
parents in Vegas and sometimes I'll take
your trip to see friends somewhere
so just Spence it's interesting our
projects come to us so ever my business
partner I have a company called innovate
productions and for instance a lot of
people we work as a creative producing
and a creative and development producing
team but we also work as a line producer
and a upm team so for the example this
project they reached out to us they need
a line producer someone who come in and
really manage this whole team for what
we're trying to do and then other times
people send us scripts and we develop
our own content and we produce it and
develop it and raise the funding and do
it ourselves and then sometimes I mean
this is we have another film going on
right now that's actually filming while
we're filming this that a friend of I
was directing yet another producer on it
who didn't know what he was doing
so they fired him and he's like we take
him we you guys come in with your
company and take over their production
for me we're like yeah absolutely
so we did that and that's another reason
why we're tired but that's yeah so we we
do a little bit we're hired but then we
also do Co productions and we partner up
with people to create our own content
and and and put things out there so we
do everything from video music videos to
commercials to feature films and we have
a music video coming up with Holly
Holmes who beat Ronda Rousey coming up
in February and then we're actually
doing a commercial with Ronda actually
with Ronda before she's already set in
place before she get beat for an energy
company that she has a sponsor that
she's a contract with so you know all
types of different fun things coming our
way and we developed a Halloween TV
special that's right now in development
that should it's in a really good
position to come out next year and so
we're kind of we're kind of moving
forward whether we create ourselves or
people hire us we just like to keep
working well Devon you said you've been
doing this 15 years is that right yeah
I've been acting since I was a child
since I was 10 and then I've been
producing for it 12 - yeah first film I
produced was 2005 so ten years okay and
so in the beginning in 2005 did you
already have n roads through the acting
where you could reach out to people or
was there a website or some place where
you went to look for people looking for
line producers or east-west um well it's
interesting because when I started when
I first said I want to produce my own
stuff very shortly after that I realized
that no one's just calling you just to
produce no one's calling to say I'm
gonna produce a film with me because
they are there Colin needed to produce
it because they need funding it's part
of a producer job is have help rates
funding for it to find the executive
producers so I taught myself the line
produced
know what involves movie magic budgeting
and just read about it and I was already
good with managing money and managing
people I said no that's not that bad
so I'd started at first thing outline
produced was a short film that was about
there's a $50,000 girlfriend pretty good
budget for a short film and just kind of
start from there and then from there
just started saying that this thing I
did was a future film that was like 200
grand and it's all he's just gonna so I
just worked my way up and so I by by by
making that transition until I'm
producing it opened up other doors for
people to actually start calling and
open up doors for producing and for
acting and for line producing and just
it was just to give us a good move for
myself because I I was doing really well
and then I hit like a brick wall you
know when I was like ah where's my
manager said when I hit a certain age I
hit a brick wall and then after a couple
years you're kind of regain your
momentum which she was dead on but
that's kind of what I did in my spare
time and now it's you know I'm lucky to
be able to have those different skills
they'll help you stay busy all the time
Devin any tips for managing people for
someone that maybe has rusty people
skills yeah if someone is having trouble
managing someone to me the best advice I
ever got was listen have patience and
then find a resolution right away I
think a lot of people try to focus on
what the problem is so there's an issue
at that point in time all I care about
is fixing the problem finding that
resolution so we can keep moving forward
once we're back on track moving forward
then I'll go back to find out how do we
get to that point to where it's
something didn't happen the way it
should have and once I started taking
that attitude it kind of helped it kind
of helped me keep things running running
smooth just because
you know we're human you know we can get
caught up in the moment and spending 15
20 minutes
you know why'd you do this and why'd you
do that and how this happen is doesn't
help anything let's fix it then we'll go
back and make the adjustment and then if
we have to keep making the adjustment
because that person keeps messing up
then unfortunately we have to let that
person go which is never fun but you
know right I rather educate someone and
help make them better at what they do
versus just going now you screwed up
once you're done so it sounds like
listen patience and fix it yeah okay I
like that
yeah that's great don't worry about how
it got there right because some people
just really did they really just make a
mistake and they just are unaware and
some people just screw up every once in
a while and we all do you know we all
make mistakes it's just that the mistake
keeps happening over over again by the
same person that's when it becomes a
problem
Devin let's take another hypothetical
someone comes to you with a maybe a
hundred thousand dollar budget and they
ask you and your partner Larry to come
and work but they can't pay you out
right they're gonna pay you once they
get distribution sort of in the back end
sure so how do you handle that first I
would read the script and it's a script
well very sorry so if someone comes to
me with a hundred thousand dollar script
and they don't want to pay and they they
feel like they can't afford to pay my
team up or Larry Knight up front but
they won't give us points on the back
end then I will say let's do a
co-production deal so right now it's
5050 and then anything divided in thing
any other points given out to anybody
else we split that evenly so what if so
we'll end up doing it like that but
again it's based on if the script is
good and then I'll say let me do a
budget for it and if I find room in the
budget even for $2,000 then we we deal
with it that way the actually the movie
we're filming now is a little bit more
of that but we are taking everything on
the back end now ten years ago five six
hey I'm saying
six years ago I want to been in that
position and do that I would said no
like I'm gonna work like I have to
okay I think a paycheck on it but
because we're so busy now I can I can
look at a project and go this is really
great project I believe in it yeah let's
list this rocket you know and then make
sure the script matches what we can
afford
and get it done and when we do that you
know we um and pay so it depends on the
people involved really but you know we
just like to make really cool content
and be proud of it and I would tell
someone like if you have a hundred
thousand dollars most people like to do
this like begging ensemble cast because
I say no don't do that put 10,000 or
15,000 towards or 20,000 towards like a
name actor that will sell your movie and
then everyone else pay them the regular
sag rate of 126 for the day but get
really good actors well people will do
it they'll put a bunch of sealed c-level
actors in the movie that's not gonna
sell you know AFM you see Steven Seagal
everywhere and we're like why the hell
Steven Seagal in all these movies like
I'm a martial artist it like out Lee I
grew up a fan of his but it's like
they're like he still sells overseas
like he's making millions of dollars
still sounding international yeah you
kick Steven 15 grand for like a week for
it to work he'll sell your movie and
take the other hundred fifteen put it
all towards proof you know so there's
worries a dope still yummy its but then
it's a question yeah we we we do do that
based on the project but I always find a
little bit of money somewhere Deven how
much are you involved in the
distribution of the film after it's made
my distribution involvement is based on
the project so if it's if I'm just lying
producing depends on the team sometimes
they're like we already have
distribution we have people that we
always work with great fantastic and
then it's other projects they're like
yeah I mean you know let's set up some
meetings with your people with set up
meetings with my people and let's just
see who gives us the best deal once at
the most so this is a project a project
basis but I'm fully involved in and on
our projects and know all about it so
that's always a good thing